-Hello, everyone,
and welcome back to the --
I don't know,
captain's quarters?
That would be a good name
for this.
Some of you might
still be confused
as to how I ended up here.
Now, as I explained on Monday,
when I gave in
to the siren call
of the magic attic door
a few weeks ago,
it led me here.
And some of you have rightfully
questioned how that works.
Did it just drop me here,
the way a Malkovich door
drops you off on the side
of the New Jersey Turnpike?
Did I walk through a tear
in the space-time continuum?
Sadly, it wasn't anything
as cool as that.
It turns out the door just leads
to this fireplace over here.
And, if you don't believe me,
here's footage of me crawling
out of it and realizing that I
am now in my in-laws' house.
Oh, [bleep] me.
So, as magical
interdimensional portals go,
it's kind of a bust.
On the plus side,
it did spit out
my beloved copy
of "The Thorn Birds".
[ Clack ]
Now, it's right up there.
But, hey, at least I have
my own space here,
where I can do my show
without any attic wasps,
unplanned Ethan Hawke cameos,
or interruptions from the ghost
of a dead sea captain.
-Arr!
I don't interrupt!
I interject!
-Anyway, speaking
of going insane,
the president
and his political allies
are telling you to suck it up
and deal with the out-of-control
coronavirus outbreak
and, if you don't like it, hey,
you can always resort
to cannibalism.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Suspenseful theme plays ]
Donald Trump is clearly upset
that he can't hold
rallies anymore,
now that attendance is so bad,
they look like Tuesday
afternoon Mets games.
So, yesterday, he lured
reporters to the Rose Garden
by pretending to hold
a press conference,
but decided, instead,
to hold a little campaign
rally, for himself,
which quickly devolved
into yet another one
of his trademark
psychotic meltdowns.
-Joe Biden's entire career
has been a gift
to the Chinese Communist Party.
They're going to abolish
immigration enforcement.
What they're going to do is
they're gonna rip down the wall.
They're taking it down.
They wanna take down the wall.
Abolish law enforcement,
as we know it.
Abolish, completely,
the death penalty.
Biden wants
to defund our military.
They want to abolish our
police departments.
They want to abolish
our prisons, I guess.
But Hunter --
Where's Hunter?
Where is Hunter, by the way?
Abolish -- in the suburbs,
you're going to abolish
the suburbs with this.
I think we have really good
poll numbers.
They're not suppression polls.
They're real polls.
You look at the lakes,
you see thousands of boats
with Trump signs.
You look at bikers,
for miles and miles,
riding up highways proudly
with their signs.
-Ah, yes, those two key
demographics,
the boats and the bikers.
Now, all you need
are the cowboys,
the construction workers,
and the leather men,
and you'll have swept
the Village People,
or, as I call them,
the Erectoral College.
-Oh, Seth!
Shame on you!
-Seriously, you know
you're desperate
when you call an official
presidential press conference
in the Rose Garden
to brag about a boat parade.
[ As Trump ]
And don't forget the Jet Skiers.
They love Trump.
Parasailers.
Bungee jumpers.
Basically, everyone
whose wife wants them
out of the house for weekends.
They're on Team Trump.
And, of course,
the coronavirus pandemic --
you know, that ongoing crisis
that has left the country
in ruins -- barely,
barely came up at all.
He basically ignored it.
That's like the fire department
showing up to a burning house,
just to sell you
their new calendar.
"Check out those six pack abs.
Either these guys
are smokin' hot
or your house is on fire.
Oh, is it?
Oh, it is on fire.
Okay, this is a case
where it's both."
It is impossible to watch
what is unfolding right now
under this administration
and avoid the conclusion
that America is in freefall.
At this very moment,
as a mostly preventible
second coronavirus outbreak
spirals further out of control,
more than 5 million Americans
have lost their
health insurance,
a third have missed
housing payments,
as many as 28 million
face eviction.
Expanded unemployment benefits
are about to expire.
People are about to get
their tax bills.
Schools might not
be able to reopen
and even the postal service
is being gutted
by soulless corporate radars
installed by our cretinous
business husk of a president.
Think about that!
We might not even be able to get
our mail in time anymore.
That's how bad things are.
And, for most of us,
getting our mail
is the only entertainment
we have left.
The only thing we have
to keep us preoccupied
is excitedly rushing
to the mailbox
to see what's 30% off in this
month's Pottery Barn catalog.
"Honey, would this wicker basket
look good in our panic room?"
And then, of course,
there's the fact
that an out-of-control
coronavirus outbreak
could dovetail with flu season
in the fall and winter,
as the CDC director
warned just yesterday.
Think about all of these
simultaneous crises
colliding at once
and how much preventible misery
that would unleash
on the country.
The only way 2020
could get any worse
is if Washington's
football team
changed their name
to the Jeffrey Epsteins.
Apologies to whoever had
to make that
in their apartment,
on the graphics team.
I don't know which one
of you did, but,
apologies and thank-yous.
And, yet, the federal
government, or Donald Trump,
could not care any less
about the anguish and pain
tens of millions of Americans
are going through.
Just this week,
the president was asked
about an Arizona teacher
who died after teaching
a summer school class
and he couldn't even muster
the minimum level
of human empathy
required to at least offer
his condolences.
-What do you tell parents
who look at this,
who look at Arizona,
where a schoolteacher
recently died
teaching summer school,
parents who are worried about
the safety of their children
in public school?
-Yeah. The schools
should be opened.
Schools should be opened.
We have to get 'em open
and I think there's a lot
of politics going along.
I think they think
they'll do better
if they can keep the schools
closed in the election.
So we just set a brand-new
record today on NASDAQ, again.
This is, now, I think,
the 18th time since --
and this is since,
after the problem.
So we have a new stock market
high for NASDAQ
and the other ones
are getting very close.
-My God, man.
Someone just asked you
about a teacher
dying from a pandemic
you failed to stop
and your response is
to brag about the NASDAQ?
Was the part of your brain
responsible for empathy
permanently damaged
in a ramp-related accident?
Man, he tiptoes down that thing
like a first-time skier
on a bunny hill.
You know, if you ever
wanna smile, just know,
if that's how he walks
down a ramp in public,
he's definitely fallen
down one, hard!, in private.
In fact, I'm pretty sure
I saw him eat it nards-first
in a YouTube compilation called
"Epic Ramp Fails!"
Trump wants schools to reopen
and I get it because we all
want schools to reopen.
No parent in America,
come Labor Day,
will be thinking,
"You know what I could use?
Some more quality time
with the kids."
The other day, my son said,
"I want to go outside,"
and I said,
"There's a lightning storm."
And he said,
"But I want to!"
And I said, "It's not safe,"
and he said,
"I don't care about safety!
I want to!"
And I said, "Oh, my God.
This is like talking
to the president
about reopening schools."
This is of course the central
feature of Trumpism,
the proud lack of empathy,
the intentional cruelty,
inflicting misery
on your opponents
and disfavored groups,
just to prove your dominance.
Trump was also asked yesterday
about the horrific murder
of George Floyd
and about
the well-documented fact
that Black people
in this country
are disproportionately more
likely to be killed by police
and, again,
rather than offer empathy
for the victims
of racist police violence,
he got mad at the question.
-Why are African Americans
still dying
at the hands of law enforcement
in this country?
-And so are white people.
So are white people.
What a terrible question to ask.
More white people, by the way.
More white people.
-That's not a...
great defense.
[ As Trump ]
Look, the police
don't see color, okay?
They just pull up
and start shooting.
And you can [bleep] right off
with your
"What a terrible question,"
since you're the guy
who popularized
such actual
terrible questions as,
"Where was Barack Obama born?"
Or "What's his real religion?"
Or...
The only thing foreign to you
about Obama's grades
would be the letters.
[ As Trump ]
An A-plus? Plus what?
What are you hiding, Obama?
Plus what?!
The only grades Trump
is familiar with are F-minus,
Incomplete, and, "Oh, sorry.
I didn't realize
who your father was."
The fact is, the rate
at which Black Americans
are shot and killed
by law enforcement
is more than twice as high
than that of white people.
You just have to do basic math,
which I know is beyond you,
since the only numbers
you're used to dealing with
are a couple of zeros.
-Oh, that be a zinger!
-The basic truth here is
that Donald Trump
just could not care any less
about racist police violence
or the coronavirus pandemic,
or the financial misery
tens of millions of Americans
are currently going through.
And, not only that,
he's doing everything he can
to make a situation worse.
His rally in Tulsa,
more than likely,
caused a spike in cases there,
according to the local
health director.
And he's still planning,
as of now,
on holding an in-person
Republican convention
next month in Florida,
which just shattered
the national record
for new daily cases.
At this point, I wouldn't be
shocked to see him
call the virus up onstage
with him at the convention.
[ As Trump ]
We love the virus.
Don't we, folks?
Ever since -- ever since
you joined the campaign,
there are more red states
than ever before.
Give it up for Rona.
Trump does not care
what happens to you
because the system
is working perfectly
for the people
he actually represents.
Namely, himself
and his fellow rich ghouls.
Billionaires have gotten
$583 billion richer
since the pandemic began.
The system is working
perfectly for them,
which is why Republican senators
have chosen to spend their time
during a once-in-a-century
cataclysm tweeting,
not about the pandemic
that's spiraling out of control
in the states they represent,
but about statues,
beans, the NBA,
and the president's golf game.
Like when Lindsey Graham
tweeted on Sunday...
Man, why does Lindsey Graham
always tweet
like he has a red laser
dot on his forehead?
[ As Graham ]
President Trump
is a great golfer.
He doesn't wanna do this.
He is just merciful, isn't he?
Isn't he?!
And, no, Trump
does not play golf fast.
He doesn't do anything fast.
He lumbers around the
White House lawn in circles
like he's lookin' for a golf
ball he shanked off the tee.
[ As Trump ]
Anyone see a Titleist 3?
Little boobs drawn on it.
The guy's Frankenstein,
if he was spraying for weeds.
"Crabgrass, bad!"
Even more deranged
than the sycophantic
dear-leader praise
of the president's golf game
is the fact that a U.S. senator
chose to spend his time
tweeting about this and not,
say, a plea to his constituents
and fellow conservatives
to wear masks,
especially since his
colleague Ted Cruz
apparently refused
to wear one on a flight.
Man, you'd think Ted Cruz would
at least wanna wear a mask
so no one would see
that his beard makes him look
like an out-of-work hedgehog.
I'm sorry, but not wearin'
a mask is now officially
the [bleep] thing
you can do on a flight.
And I am including wearing
open-toed sandals.
You foot freaks are off the hook
until this pandemic is over.
This is the conservative
movement of Donald Trump,
a movement that rejects
science and empathy
in favor of dumb
culture war grievances
like statues and cancel culture.
As a highly infectious deadly
disease spreads like wildfire,
the supposedly pro-life party
has abandoned you.
Scared of gettin' sick?
The White House says, "Too bad,
we need to live with it."
Lost your job amid
the worst economic crisis
since the Great Depression?
The only advice they have is
find something new,
courtesy of the new ad campaign
rolled out by Ivanka Trump,
who, famously, has found
many jobs on her own,
with no help from her father.
Ivanka Trump is the last person
who should be lecturing anyone
on learning new skills
to cope with a job loss.
The only skills she has are
having a rich father,
making scarves that catch fire,
and unnaturally holding up
a can of beans,
as she demonstrated
with this incredibly dumb
and, most likely,
illegal tweet last night,
advertising Goya
after the CEO praised Trump.
She looks like she's auditioning
to be a game show model
in the '80s.
"Oh, the vaccine was
behind door number 1,
but you've won a year's
supply of Goya beans!
Show 'em the beans, Ivanka."
What do you even call
a person who takes that photo
in the middle of a pandemic?
-The bean queen!
She won't be likin'
that nickname.
-[ Chuckling ]
-Oh, thank you, Sea Captain.
-It be me pleasure.
-But it's not just
the Trump White House.
Millionaire right-wing pundits
are also telling you,
from the safety and comfort
of their homes and studios,
to suck it up and deal with it.
Here's Fox News host
Laura Ingraham on Monday,
arguing that the coronavirus
is just something
we have to live with.
-No more lockdowns.
Viruses are a fact of life.
And it's very sad.
And sometimes, as with COVID-19,
there will be awful,
tragic results.
-Oh, so viruses are just
a fact of life?
Cool. Then, why don't you take
your show on the road
and do it on location
from an Amazon warehouse
or a meatpacking plant?
Hell, do it on an airplane.
Start a new segment
where you prove viruses
aren't a big deal
by inviting people
to cough on you.
You can sit next to Ted Cruz.
11B is open.
On Tuesday, Rush Limbaugh
cited the Donner Party --
you know, the cannibals --
as an example of how we should
adapt to the pandemic.
[ Laughing ]
And I really --
Guys, I really wish
I was exaggerating, but,
yeah, I'm not.
-The Donner Party,
the Donner family
and a bunch of travelers tryin'
to get to California
over the Sierra Nevada
Mountain range.
They made the mistake
of tryin' to make the trip
in the middle of winter.
We're talkin'
the Lake Tahoe region.
They get to the peak.
It was so bad
that they had to turn
to cannibalism to survive!
That's what's noteworthy
about the Donner Party.
If you read the diaries
written by the leaders
of the Donner Party,
the only reference
to how cold it was
was one sentence --
"It was a particularly
tough winter."
It's just what was.
They didn't complain about it
because there was nothing
they could do.
They had to adapt!
This is what's missing!
There seems to be no concept
of adaptation!
There seems to be
no understanding,
in the millennial generation,
that we can adapt to this
and that we're gonna have to.
-Finally, the Republicans
[ Laughing ]
have found a message
to run on...
This psycho right there?
He's got a Presidential
Medal of Freedom.
Next time we tune into his show,
he's probably gonna be
gnawing on it.
[ As Limbaugh ]
See? We don't need food.
Gold -- gold tastes delicious.
Can't wait
for Ivanka's new tweet,
holdin' up a femur with a recipe
for how to cook it.
"Soak it in broth
for 30 minutes.
Mix in some carrots and peas
and, voilà!
You've got Carl soup."
We're witnessing
an unprecedented failure
of American governance,
brought about by a political
movement that couldn't care less
what happens to you
or your loved ones.
A series of crises are heading
for a disastrous collision
and the Trumps and Ivankas
and Limbaughs and Ingrahams
and Cruzes and Grahams
of the world,
they just don't care.
But, as we've seen,
time and time again
in Trump world, when this grift
of theirs comes crashing down,
they'll turn on each other,
because they always do,
and, when that happens,
we'll be able to say...
-It was so bad,
that they had to turn
to cannibalism to survive!
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
So many New Yorkers are needing
to turn to City Harvest
for help feeding their families,
and they need your support.
Now, more than ever,
if you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Wash your hands.
We love you.